today we're talking about hybrid work
cloud run cpu and cloud spanner i'm jen
person and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
lots of folks around the world are
working in new ways across a broad range
of locations and working hours workspace
has added new features to help you work
effectively with your teams for example
spaces lets you collaborate while
integrating calendar drive docs and more
the blog post has info about new
hardware setting flexible locations and
hours and quickly connecting with
teammates so check out the full details
cloudrun gives you the ability to run
containers in a serverless platform and
only charges for cpu and memory used
during a request or event
but what if your container workload
requires background processing well now
you can allocate always on cpu to ensure
your app will have access to the
resources needed while still giving you
the benefit of low offs
there's a lot of cool stats around cloud
spanner and how you can take advantage
of the strong consistency and high
availability if you haven't had a chance
to try it out now is the perfect time
with this walkthrough follow along to
deploy a sample application on cloud run
and spanner by using terraform and then
scale up spanner if you want even more
check out the repository of other
terraform examples
are you a fan of the command line but
wish you could get better visibility
never fear katie is here with a quick
get extension git deploy katie breaks
down how git hooks and extensions work
and demonstrates get deployed to help
you see more details from cloud build by
streaming the logs all with one command
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you